with Valentine's Day right around the
corner Bachelorette alum Andi Dorfman is
spilling on her do's and don'ts of
dating okay what is the best and worst
dating advice you've ever received best
relationship advice ever be nice to
someone it and find someone that's nice
to you so simple but if you think about
it find somebody that's nice it's that
simple
yeah I heard this about a couple months
ago and I'm like my eyes wide open up
something so simple took the worst
dating advice
you know plate-like I hate when people
say play the game like don't play the
game just put it down like you don't
need to play the game that was for high
school that was for college like once
you get a certain point you don't need
to play the game a good date is someone
who's creative somebody who thinks of
something like whether it's a show
whether it's a certain place for dinner
don't just do the average you know
run-of-the-mill guy that does like
dinner
you never take a girl to the movies on
the first day that's just like that's
makes me like we don't want to hear you
talk right you have some creativity
whether it's the type of restaurant
whether it's an activity like something
that shows that you put a little thought
into it now done and always bring wine I
feel so bad for the next guy to hate
this I've had like first dates and
helicopters castles boys to men concerts
I mean come on the bar is pretty high
I've peaked